I gotta walk it off yeah yeah go ahead
I gotta water it off take a lap though
oh my god dude what's the hottest
[ __ ] thing I've ever ate hey what's
going on everybody first we feast I'm
Sean Evans and you're watching hot ones
it's the show of hot questions and even
hotter wings and at long last I'm joined
by Bill burr Billy's one of the biggest
stand-up comedians in the game you know
him as the host of the Monday morning
podcast as the co-creator and star of
Netflix's f is for family now entering
its third season bells welcome to the
show thank you for having me
well it's good to have you in this seat
finally how are you spicy food you can't
get up a little bit I a little bit I
know I don't get crazy
I'd like this is gonna beat all the
comedic elements that you want it's
gonna have look at me I'm pasty as hell
yeah you would I'd be like most of my
[ __ ] was boiled growing up very bland
you know salt and pepper was about as
hard as we went in our house
[Music]
all right bill so this first one meeting
the whole thing - man these chickens
died man you got to eat him well you
know I'll remember that you said that
you know if you stick with that I'll
stick with that and I'll eat the whole
wing right along with you it's a time of
waste so what is the one this is the
classic the classic we've got some wind
roll all right so you've been dealing
with this mass whole stereotype your
whole life I think do a lot of audiences
you're their first exposure to this New
England accent and sensibilities so what
I want to do is bounce some Boston
related stories about the haunting I was
a little bigger than my [ __ ] act but
okay I'll give it to you all right so
what I want to ambassador from
Massachusetts Dunkin Donuts removing
doughnuts from the name do people care
about that embossed as much as they seem
to on the internet so they're called
Dunkin mmm-hmm that is a incredibly
[ __ ] stupid idea you think so yes I
mean how bored were they like how much
money were they making it at those
places were they're like hey let's let's
[ __ ] with what everybody knows they over
they overthink [ __ ] I mean it's their
company I wouldn't have done it Boston
drivers are no longer the worst in the
country according to Allstate does that
ring true to you um well this is this is
how I've driven everywhere in this
country pretty much East Coast they're
bad but they're aggressively bad I don't
mind
aggressively bad cuz whatever you did
eventually you're gonna get the [ __ ] out
of my way right mm-hmm
out here they're just bad you got to do
like a hundred miles an hour to get off
the highway but when you get on the
surface streets it's like they're
staring at their phones or they took a
pot cookie oh and people who ride bikes
in LA are morons morons they [ __ ]
dress up like they're in a bike race and
then they just drive out in the road and
they always yell share the road it's
like well yeah yeah you too
move over move all I allowed enough time
to get there in a car not follow you on
your [ __ ] bicycle Lance
and I know I'm not saying that's not a
bad thing when they die but it's not
shocking are you stop baking uh yeah you
know a lot of people think that baking
versus regular cooking it's a
personality you tell like being a cat
person or a dog person do you think
theirs might be something about the
precision of baking that appeals to you
I think if somebody had us like a
psychology background they could
actually say that but I'm guessing most
of that was by people who maybe took one
site class no people get freaked out by
baking is actually easy you just do
exactly what they tell you to do I'm
actually learning now how to how to cook
more healthy because I'm [ __ ] old I'm
50 you know making smoothies yeah I had
like hummus sandwich before I came over
here it's actually good you feel light
afterwards then you feel kind of
energized you know my big thing now is
lentil burgers I mean I'm not gonna lie
to you like I'll still I still like blue
beer and like I don't know root beers my
thing though and then I know that you're
a Food Network fan back in the day are
you still entertained by food TV airs
that lost a little bit of its charm oh
it's competition yes once they started
yelling at each other and it's just like
okay you gotta make pancakes you have a
toaster and a [ __ ] chicken wing it's
just like like cooking supposed to be
relaxing and it's one of them like the
one of the nicest things you can do for
somebody by the way I appreciate the
free chicken here got your belt you know
you just add all this pressure to it
like I always found out like I worked in
a kitchen and there were times when they
were screaming and yelling but when you
watch those shows where it's just all
screaming yelling it's just for for the
TV I always want to read that Anthony
Bourdain book but I'm like it makes me
go to sleep
can we eat another one sure oh this one
looks good maple wood smoked onions ice
[Music]
all right I'm not gonna lie to you
mm-hmm
who's about as hard as I usually go
there are number three are you still
committed to that idea of eating all ten
no I'm gonna I'm definitely gone I mean
what's up this is just a whole bit is to
watch somebody [ __ ] knows run yeah
exactly
salute bill so as we touch on your intro
f is for family as entering its third
season in addition to creating it and
starring it I know that you're making
the doughnuts in the writers room and
stand-up it's such a solitaire game you
know goes from your brain to the
audience with no filter what's different
to you about the collaborative process
of the writers room the lack of respect
that writers get like how [ __ ] hard
it is you know I mean everybody talks
about actors oh he gained weight for
this and how did you get your abs it's
just like dude like somebody [ __ ] sat
in and just like missed his kids growing
up so you could go out and go be [ __ ]
you know I don't know whatever the flash
whenever the [ __ ] they do when movies
about nowadays and then Netflix seems to
be in the middle of this comedy gold
rush you know from these multi-million
dollar Dave Chappelle deals to the
stand-up specials the original series
like f is for family and I'm curious
about your perspective on Netflix and
its impact on the business of comedy I
my first our special idea now why do I
do this I remember clearly upset The
Improv on Melrose and somebody said what
do you want for the intro and I said
blah blah blah blah you can watch his
new special why do I do this on Netflix
and the guy said it and people snickered
in the crowd saw that's how long I've
been with those guys they would like
still consider the guys that delivered
videos to you and they thought it was
funny and then like within like I think
three years of that they were like the
place to be so that in Breaking Bad were
two things that I got in on early and I
feel like if I didn't I would have I
would have probably got lost in the herd
Breaking Bad I saw you know the first
episode immediately asked my agent I can
do anything I'll carry the meth in the
background anything so I think I got in
early with the request all right what do
we got here
oh I [ __ ] love that you clean it off
mine I did check check the kid Redbird
right now
I'm right with you I'm right with you
I'm leaving nothing on the new I had a
woman one time come up to me after a
show and tell me that she was a
card-carrying member of PETA I forget
what joke I did was she upset about a
joke that yeah but she's not a
card-carrying member of Peter like oh
yeah you know you do sign up actually
she got a [ __ ] MBA so you once called
the countenance of sports writers
unparalleled and these days there does
seem to be a lot of outrage born coming
from the dweebs who cover professional
sports so what I want to do is just
bounce some hot-button barroom debates
off of you because I think the
nosebleeds need bilborough's perspective
starting to sweat feel it are you
looking forward to seeing maroon 5 and
cardi B perform at this year's Super
Bowl halftime show I just hate how it's
the most important football game of the
year and they do it and they is just so
much other [ __ ] going on and all these
people who don't give a [ __ ] about
football show up and they talk during
the game and then they shut up during
the commercials and then when the game
comes back on the way how much you think
that would cost and it's just like so I
don't I try not to go to Super Bowl
parties because I always end up in the
kitchen on that that little [ __ ] TV
or whatever so what do you think is a
sillier protest cutting up your nike
socks or burning your LeBron Jersey I
would stick both equally stupid but
because of what was behind Colin
Kaepernick it was wait it's just I just
hate you knew you knew this second he
did it it was eventually gonna be like
my brothers fighting in Iraq and it's
just like dude nobody is saying your
brother isn't fighting in Iraq he's
talking about police brutality this is
what it is and how that was just
hijacked and also you know he's on his
knees that's more respectful than
standing upright taking your hat off
I get it I don't understand the
experience because I'm [ __ ] white you
know I look like a cup so I'm very like
ninety anyways cops just wave at me they
think they know me but uh yes I'm comics
steel jokes some cops [ __ ] kill
people not saying to get rid of all the
cops they just
take get rid of the bad ones it's very
logical argument I built we every crane
segment our show called explain that
Graham we do a deep dive and I guess
Instagram pull interesting pictures that
need more context so I'll bust out the
laptop I'll show you the picture and you
just tell me the bigger story does that
sound good if you talked really fast
all right laptop please you know I'm
actually drinking water right now cuz I
was so drunk sorry bill I can recommend
some place yeah once you go to wings
John Hannah I'm not blowing it up here I
don't have to stand in line in my same
[ __ ] my favorite place what is the
craziest bout you saw when you're doing
color commentary at rough and rowdy that
amateur boxing event oh god I think the
two brothers that fought each other
there was two brothers and one of them
was in the Armed Forces and was like you
know making stuff from himself the other
one didn't have a job or something and
played video games and he hated his mom
saying his mother loved the other one
better
so he's like in the shadow of his older
but this is the best thing his brother
who's in the military agreed said yeah
she likes me better so it was under and
then he said that people in the armed
services were overrated they're not that
tough
and then they went out and they beat the
[ __ ] out of each other again I want to
say the video game kid won but what was
funny was they were both in the same
shape so this guy never even got off the
couch this other guy you know he had to
go through basic training another thing
I was kind of amazed by that that was a
good one it's you know it's one of the
things I really grew up watching a lot
of those tough man competitions and the
fact that barstool brought him back was
it's just been a lot of fun so I'm so
like those guys
let me come on everyone someone the next
one is October 5th I don't know when
this comes out it will have already fed
out I don't know what I guess going to
the backlog or so yeah going to the
backlog what do you remember about your
conversation with Danica Patrick you
guys talked about classic cars I know
she was like just dialed in like she had
like astronaut Chuck Yeager like just it
was awesome like [ __ ] hands like vise
handshake and what was funny
was when we got in the car and we were
driving around the Indianapolis 500
which I had been to I've gone to it
twice and and it's just you come down
the straightaway it's iconic it's as I
can't explain it's like my god I think
I've ever saw a changing fight and all
these guys Rick me is and all these
people growing up I was talking to her
about how she was gonna retire after the
race she said she was retired yeah you
know I heard you retire and I'm like
that's that's awesome you retire and she
little eats you punch me in the shoulder
she was like thanks cuz I guess
everybody's giving her [ __ ] yeah she
drove she spun out in the race you know
went out in a blaze of glory and I yeah
I thought it was a really cool way to
retire some of your casual fans might
not know that you're a licensed
helicopter pilot why the same hat look I
only got one hat look at this is the
same man hey I'm a minimalist flying a
helicopter learning how to do that is
one of the biggest accomplishments of my
life because I did not do well in school
and I was really nervous about ground
school and all of that me being able to
pass and I actually discovered that if
I'm into something that it's not it's
it's not like those classes you just you
know you just went to school me just
whatever they were teaching you had to
learn it right whether it engaged your
brain or not so not saying I'm not a
[ __ ] but I was pretty surprised that I
was able to be able to do that so well
Congrats bill thank you
[Music]
all right like that that little cumin in
there mm-hmm huh hey I cook I like that
I hear you [ __ ] bucket yeah all right
so it's interesting watching you on late
shows because sometimes I get this sense
that when you're watching the audience
they can't tell if it's okay to laugh or
not
from your perspective are you amused by
that or annoyed by that um there's just
a lot of that right now there's just a
lot up no uh-uh
you know you say something and people
act like somebody just got hurt I don't
understand it but you know it's it's
what the young people do and I respect
it yeah most people out there are not
Fanning themselves every time somebody
says something they they understand they
understand context they understand two
sides of the story they understand due
process they understand all of this
stuff like I think you should be allowed
to disagree which this kind of seems to
be going away
[Music]
that went up a notch mm-hmm this is one
of these lingering ones where you think
you handled it another chance all right
yeah you going for your milk
not until you do you know I'm going step
for step with you I think milk is a
coward I think that's a cowardly move
then I think Isis wins can go for the
milk I'm sweating right now dude that's
[ __ ] hot what's like annoying yeah
what the [ __ ] would you do that to
somebody's food oh now it's a mission
that was just all mm-hmm and then this
is now we're now are in the rapids it's
going down now we get to see who we are
as men I might have to take the hat off
to it go ahead there's no shame in that
you know I don't have to head off Isis
wins but the Hat that can come off I'm
52 you can't be doing this to me dad
would my forehead like a preacher so
want to take a wing to talk about the
Monday morning podcast cuz you're really
on that wave early in fact you predate
Joe Rogan and Marc Maron and I'm curious
with all these people who blew by me
yeah a head start on all these guys
around when you read always run it when
you were doing it back then did you feel
like you were breaking new ground or has
the podcast industry and its explosion
particularly in comedy surprised you it
was just when I did it I was when I
first started it was like five minutes I
would call up to my eyes and water I
would just call up this disservice the
OK's bill I'm gonna be you to call me
works in Denver oh you were gonna - it
was only a couple minutes then just kept
getting longer and longer and longer and
longer yeah I kind of learned how to
podcast as it just grew so I grew as a
podcaster I hope and then there's this
push to make content shorter more
snackable but comedians in particular
seem to be comfortable uploading these
four hour-long sit-downs do you think
for the comic mind there's a certain
freedom and that kind of medium now
probably just lazy
I don't was that you're editing this
flow that is hot
how do advertisers react when you goof
in the ad reads do you find that
companies kind of get it I think I lost
I think I probably lost one with the
toilet seat company today
sometimes you just gotta burn one you
just gotta burn one today all right yeah
I'll give you your money back because
this [ __ ] is just stupid [ __ ]
electric toilet seat with a remote
control
I'll just as seriously sell that dude
you barely even touched your water man
you're a [ __ ] pro oh we're going
again that's all the giddy where you
fightin the champ Ryan you're like all
right surround five you know you know he
was just sizing you up all right he's
called the bomb
[Music]
I'm enough I have tastes awful yeah I
got I imagine that this is just the
beginning of the awful of this one that
might be hitting the sack soon
hit the water good moment oh my god
mm-hmm I could barely talk says we've
touched on your huge sports fan and I
was impressed to learn that you've been
to almost every major sports stadium and
what like ten straight Rose Bowls am I
supposed to answer that dude holy [ __ ]
and the booty really milk I know I did
all right I'm going milk I gotta go mom
and the foodie revolution is in on
atrocious room temperature who does that
to somebody and the foodie revolution
has really infiltrated this stadium and
I'm curious you have any thoughts museum
two-foot-long tamale Laden dog down my
throat or creme brulee french toast
being served at Fenway don't breathe
through your mouth goes into your throat
oh don't touch my eyes mm-hmm dude what
tough [ __ ] that's worse than India now
say India's a bad place apologize huh I
gotta walk it off yeah yeah go ahead
take a lap though oh my god dude what's
the hottest [ __ ] thing I've ever yeah
oh my god oh [ __ ] it's not going away
mm-hmm
oh my god mm-hmm
so the foodie revolution that's really
infiltrated this stadium I don't give a
[ __ ] where people eat I just hate the
flat-screen TVs
ah it's out of my eyes now mm-hmm it's a
good place to be oh my god headed in the
right direction what I think I was gonna
be able to do this craft beer is another
thing that's infiltrated the stadium and
you know when I was a kid you'd go to a
game it would just be dad brands it
would just be Budweiser old style and
now there are like 10 local IPAs on tap
I know that you get really into the
weeds of good food good cigars have you
been bitten by the craft beer bug oh no
I hate those beers you know they always
have tough names you know go [ __ ]
yourself ale slap your mother larger
wicked [ __ ] whatever the [ __ ] they call
it they're just super hoppy can I ask
you a question is it all in your nose
right now is that normal or did I just
tell you I touch it with my hands yeah
you know you got to be careful it's
contaminated right but if you don't want
it to get worse - [ __ ] this
I don't know about this dude I don't if
I can make this you can do it you can do
it what is the upside I already promoted
the [ __ ] cartoon what do you think is
the most I am [ __ ] miserable right
now yeah oh no bill I know I've seen a
lot of crazy [ __ ] from this side of the
tape have you yeah but I shouldn't watch
this [ __ ] before it came in wow that was
[ __ ] like that was an experience dude
this is [ __ ] nuts so since leaving
Boston you've split your time between
New York and Los Angeles what I want to
do is bounce a few points of comparison
with those cities and you tell me which
city reigns supreme sound good yeah sure
between those cities where do you find
the better comedy crowds okay for the
longest time it was it was New York
hands-down now I like LA better no New
York is just like it's like don't stand
up in a like a woman's college it's a
combination of that or you feel like
you're talking about your old people on
a cruise ship the whole [ __ ] set
which is the better food city in your
opinion they're both amazing food cities
and they're both good at what they do I
feel like I'm running for office right
now because the pits out here sucks
but the pizza back there is amazing if
you know where to go cuz there's a lot
of people that live off the reputation
of New York Pizza but uh but like out
here the burgers obviously Mexican food
Thai food sushi is [ __ ] crazy yeah
dude I I think you are more relentless
than these [ __ ] wings
where does a guy like you feel more at
home you this is like with my wife after
a while you just tap out you're like
fine by it I don't give a [ __ ] because
la seems so opposite of Boston and the
New York there's this fierce rivalry
where do you feel more at home I can't
even hear anyone I feel at home in my
house which is where I wish I might
[ __ ] take a giant milk bath when I
come home it's good [ __ ] okay what are
you doing all right bill this is the
last dad or like holidays is different
the last dad because we put a little
extra on the last wing it's drink enough
fire you don't have to if you don't want
to oh I know that talk you don't have to
you [ __ ] [ __ ] what are you doing one
this little little dab on there I'm
going to whoa you like that [ __ ] you
respect I will do out of solidarity in
because I can't have you making me look
like a [ __ ] in my own show okay it's
been fun thanks Bill
he'll be back
I'm
this is a bad time to ask me I'd like to
say it will be alright
salut Cheers alright [ __ ] I come fast
you're trying to eat these last ones
I've seen you before they're over
[Music]
I'm Martin beat mentally I have you beat
I'm trying to run right now you did the
second you walked it from the final
round you're running you think you're
ahead on points right now got it
if you leave it up to the judges this
last one was delicious thanks Bill we
actually make this one my man my man Wow
all right bill here we are at the end of
the line ten wings up ten wings down so
you're maybe the most requested guest in
hot ones history and as a result there's
been all this wreckage [ __ ] you to all
your people speculation on the ship
about how you might perform on the show
so the following are comments that we
actually pulled from a Bill burr fan
page on reddit with your own fans
guessing how you might perform on hot
one so I'll be do the comment you can
react to the comic dog I've got you in
the throat mm ah yeah right he gets four
wings in before his face goes so red
that sean has to swap the milk for some
sunscreen standard redhead bashing I'm
used to it go ahead Bills ears will be
like two steam whistles I like that one
he won't even hear himself violently
[ __ ] his me undies
okay podcast listener thank you I don't
know if I want to see that I know what I
look like eating spicy food it'll be
twice as bad on bill since he's bald oh
look like a damn tomato I would have
gone with Hellboy but okay all right
bill look at you proving them all wrong
because you took down the gauntlet bone
cleaning
that's your rankings wrong here yeah
what would you do how would you switch
it up yep yeah
that's all I said that's like when when
that team that should have been in the
college football playoff doesn't make it
the fifth one yep
the fifth guy the odd man out there's
UCF right there I was going to say yes
Central Florida man hey I - I bill and
that's exactiy my was gonna pick there's
nothing left to do but roll out the red
carpet for you my friend this camera
this camera at this camera let the
people know what you have going on at
your life well I imagine at this point
my life I'm preparing for Thanksgiving
[Music]
getting off the road other than I'm
happy I made it through well I am - look
at you you King the kids your new king I
surmise gonna eat that [ __ ] cheese
when I was in Norway the cheese in
Norway I hate this cheese in no way that
just [ __ ] you know my wife kept
laughing going stop it stop cuz she bit
into it she said oh my god with those
places that has cheese for dessert
mm-hmm
you know one of those [ __ ] places and
it was just so [ __ ] I don't know what
it wasn't like hot but it was into
whatever it did to you it just made
everything just pouring out she kept
telling me to stop and mo she told me to
stop I just kept shoving bigger pieces
and she was it was this really fancy
restaurant and she was crying laughing
and she was embarrassed
it was everything why I love my wife
around there we go we're end on that
nice thing people have quit you can't
quit I agree with you on her percent the
cameras went on I went quit that was not
enjoyable hey what's going on spice
Lords this is Sean Evans checking in by
his lonesome and you know what that
means it's time for another hot sauce
PSA and for two years we've been working
on making the perfect entry level sauce
something that's good for everyone
number one on our board and now it is
finally here the classic is our
contemporary twist on the original
vinegar-based sauces throughout American
history
with chile de árbol peppers and garlic
for that perfect balance as always
people who order the hot ones monthly
subscription box got it first but now
it's available for everyone
heat nice calm heat nice calm to pick up
the classic the classic it's for the
people
[Music]